we first told you yesterday about an
audio clip that's dividing friends
families and coworkers
do you hear the word Danny or Laurel
yeah yeah yeah so yeah knee so what do
you think Twitter data actually shows
47% of people on the site here yeah knee
oh and 53% here Laurel wired
editor-in-chief in CBS News contributor
Nick Thompson is here to try and settle
it for us Nick
how can people hear such difference
between these two words it's being
described as an optical illusion for
your ears two words that look so
different on paper but can sound so
alike that's now causing us to rethink
what we hear yeah yeah this one
recording has led to a big debate split
in the internet in to everyone is taking
sides some on team Yanni others on team
Laurel the story that's tearing the
country apart
it is Laurel and not Yanni yes even the
legendary performer who shares one of
the names waited
it's perhaps the biggest internet
controversy since the great white and
gold poor blue and black dress debate of
2015 so which one is it
if you said Laurel you're technically
correct I thought I was losing it last
Friday Georgia High School student
Katie Hetzel was studying the word
Laurel for her literature class and
decided to research it on vocabulary
calm I clicked the audio button to tell
me Ward spell and I heard a Yeti and I
was like this isn't one of my vocabulary
words the high school freshman posted
her findings to Instagram soon enough
the internet worked it's magic and the
debate turned explosive so we decided to
conduct our own experiment
she's crazy linguist Ben Zimmer people
are more attuned to the high frequencies
are picking up on things that make it
sound more like yen if you're not
picking up on those higher frequencies
then it sounds more like Laurel
well Cabul Ericom where the debate
originated has now gotten in the action
creating a definition for all of the
people on Team Jonnie Jonnie is a word
or phrase that is capable of distracting
the entire internet for at least 24
hours when you drop a Yeti you start a
contentious debate on some type of
public forum sorry I'm dropping a
million yeah knees right now because it
is so clearly an e to me no a we hear we
hear Laurel weird Laurel and therefore
we are right that was easily settled I
don't know what everybody's talking
about I mean it is kind of amazing
because what it shows is that stuff in
the world can be real and then our
brains create illusions around it where
they fill in the space this would
explain if it actually extrapolated to
this which I'm sure it doesn't all the
music that people like that I think why
do they like that song exactly they just
hear a different thing thanks Nick yeah
thank you